on the first day of action at the Winter
Olympics in South Korea North Korea
tried to steal the spotlight with a huge
military parade thousands of soldiers
marched in the capital the North
displayed two different versions of the
intercontinental ballistic missiles that
it says could strike the u.s. about 120
miles away vice president Mike Pence
arrived in Seoul South Korea CBS News
White House reporter Jackie Alemany is
traveling with the vice president Jackie
good morning good morning vice president
Mike Pence held bilateral talks with
South Korean president moon jae-in on
Thursday said against the backdrop of a
2018 Olympics complicated by the threat
of a neighbor with nuclear ambitions the
two put forth a united front towards
denuclearizing North Korea despite
behind-the-scenes discord over South
Korea's Olympics often ignored the north
as the two prepare to march in the
Olympics under one flag the United
States of America will continue to stand
shoulder-to-shoulder in our effort to
bring maximum pressure to bear until
that time comes when they finally and
permanently
otto warmbier fred joined vice president
pence and the US delegation to the
olympics today in seoul otto was
arrested in Pyongyang in 2015 after
allegedly stealing a propaganda Stein he
was allegedly tortured and died shortly
after returning to the u.s. to nekoma
last year a White House official said
Fred Warren be his presence at the
Olympics serves as a reminder to the
world of the atrocities being committed
in North Korea Nora
all right Jackie Alemanni in South Korea
thank you